the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi in the last unit we introduced the
notion of the structure of vectors in
terms of arrows in the plane and today
we want to talk about the added
geometric property of what I could call
three dimensional vectors or three
dimensional arrows now before I say that
I guess I've already said it but before
I say any more about it let me point out
of course that this is a matter of
semantics obviously an arrow being
aligned has only one dimension be it in
the direction of the x axis be it in the
XY plane or be it in three-dimensional
space when we say three-dimensional
vectors we do not negate the fact that
we're talking about arrows but rather
that we are dealing with a coordinate
system which takes into consideration
the fact that the line is drawn through
three-dimensional space in other words
whereas I call the lecture
three-dimensional vectors or arrows and
by the way both in the notes and as I'm
lecturing I will very often whenever I
write the word vector put arrow in
parenthesis whenever I write the word
arrow put vector in parenthesis so you
can see the juxtaposition between these
two the geometry versus the physical or
mathematical concept but the idea is
something like this in three-dimensional
space we have a natural extension of
Cartesian coordinates rather than talk
about the XY plane we pick a third axis
a third number line which goes through
the origin perpendicular to the XY plane
and which has the sense that if the x
axis is rotated into the y axis through
the positive 90 degree angle here that
the z axis is in the direction in which
a right handed screw would turn I won't
belabor this it's done very very nicely
in the textbook and I'm sure that you
have seen this type of coordinate system
before if you haven't it's something
that takes a matter of some 20 or 30
seconds to pick up but at any rate what
we're saying is let's imagine this three
dimensional coordinate system three
dimensional Cartesian cord
the convention is that just as in the
plane we label the point by its x and
y-components
in 3-space a point is labeled by its XY
and z components so for example if I
take a vector in three space meaning
what it's a line that goes through three
dimensional space I again shifted
parallel to itself so it begins at my
origin and at the risk of causing some
confusion here I still think it's worth
doing let me call the vector a and let
me call the point at which the vector
terminates the point a and let's suppose
at the point a has coordinates a1 a2 a3
the reason that this doesn't make much
difference if you get confused is that
if the vector which originates at the
origin terminates at the point whose
coordinates are a 1 a 2 and a 3 then the
components of that vector will have what
the I component will be a1 the J
component will be a 2 and by the way we
let K be the unit vector in the positive
z direction and the K component will be
a 3 to see this thing's pictorially
notice that the three-dimensional effect
of the vector a it means that if we drop
a perpendicular from the head of a to
the XY plane then you see this distance
is a 1 this distance is a 2 and this
height is a 3 and notice again in terms
of adding vectors head-to-tail etc
notice that as a vector this would be
the vector a 1 I this would be the
vector a 2 J and this would be the
vector a 3 K in other words the vector a
is the sum of the three vectors a 1 I a
2 J and a 3 K in other words to
summarize this the vector a is simply
what a 1 I plus a 2 J plus a 3 K and
again notice the juxtapositioning if you
wish between the components of the
vector and the coordinates of the point
also we can get a hold of the magnitude
of this vector remember that magnitude
is the length and how can we figure out
the length of this vector notice it by
the way the geometry gets much tougher
in three-dimensional space but I'm going
to show you something interesting there
let's suffer through the geometry for a
minute let's see how we can find the
length of the vector a well notice by
the way that a happens to be of a
magnitude of a happens to be the
hypotenuse of a right triangle what
right triangle is it it's the right
triangle that joins the origin let me
call this point here B and a in other
words triangle oba is a right triangle
because OB is in the XY plane and a B is
perpendicular to the XY plane therefore
by the Pythagorean theorem the magnitude
of a will be the square root of the
square of the magnitude of OB plus the
square of the magnitude of a B on the
other hand notice that o see B is also a
right triangle so by the Pythagorean
theorem the length of OB is the square
root of a 1 squared plus a 2 squared and
therefore you see by the Pythagorean
theorem the square of the magnitude of a
is this squared plus this squared in
other words the magnitude of a is the
square root of a 1 squared plus a 2
squared plus a 3 squared in other words
in Cartesian coordinates to find the
magnitude of a vector you need only take
the positive square root of the sum of
the squares of the components it's the
regular distance formula the Pythagorean
theorem by the way just a very very
quick review from part 1 of our course
remember that technically speaking the
square root is a double valued function
namely any positive number has two
square roots right in other words the
square root of 16 is 4 it's also
negative 4 but by convention when we
don't indicate a sign we're always
referring to the positive square root
and that's fine because after all the
magnitude the length of an arrow is
always looked upon as being what some
non-negative number notice that the
negativeness is taken care of by the
sense okay and this is what's rather
interesting I think it's worth noting if
we use Cartesian coordinates in one
dimension all you have is the x axis in
which case any vector is some scalar
multiple of the unit vector I in other
words a is equal to a 1 I in this case
the magnitude of a is just what it's the
square root of a 1 squared and notice
that means the positive square root
notice by the way that that's the usual
meaning of absolute value after all if a
1 were already positive taking the
positive square root of its square root
of its square these tongues versus the
positive square root of the square would
give you a number back again on the
other hand if a 1 were negative and then
you square it and then take the positive
square root all you do is change the
sign of a 1 when since it was negative
changing its sign makes it positive so
this is the usual absolute value all
right now in terms of the previous unit
we saw that in two dimensional space
using I and J as our basic vectors that
if a was the vector a 1 I plus a 2 J
then the magnitude of a again by the
Pythagorean theorem was just a square
root of a 1 squared plus a 2 squared and
now we've seen that structurally even
though geometrically it was harder to
show that the that if a in
three-dimensional space is a 1 I plus a
2 J plus a 3 K then a is what the
positive square root of a 1 squared plus
a 2 squared plus a 3 squared and notice
you see this structural resemblance this
is a beautiful structural resemblance
why is it the beautiful structural
resemblance because now maybe we're
getting the feeling that once our rules
and recipes are made up we don't have to
worry about how difficult the geometry
is in other words except for the fact
that you have an extra component to
worry about here there is no basic
difference structurally between finding
the length of a vector in one
dimensional space or in
three-dimensional space and in fact
another reason that I'm
rapping on this is the fact that in a
little while meaning within the next few
lessons we are going to be talking about
some horrible thing called n dimensional
space which geometrically cannot be
drawn but which analytically preserves
the same structure that we're talking
about here you see the whole bag is
still this idea of structure we're
trying to emphasize that the recipes
remain the same independently of the
dimension and just to carry this idea a
few steps further what we're saying is
remember in the last unit we talked
about the fact that the nice thing about
I and J components was that the
definition for adding two vectors was
that if they were in terms of I and J
components you just added component by
component well again without belaboring
the point and leaving the details to the
text and to the exercises let's keep in
mind that it's relatively easy to show
that the same formal definition of
addition namely placing the arrows head
to tail etc forgetting about Cartesian
coordinates but notice the definition of
addition doesn't mention the coordinate
system it just says put the vectors head
to tail etc and what I'm saying is it's
easy to show under those conditions that
if a is the vector a 1 I plus a 2 J plus
a 3 K and B is the vector B 1 I plus B 2
J plus B 3 K then you still add vectors
the same way in 3-space as you did in
2-space again the geometric arguments
are a little bit more sophisticated if
only because it's harder to draw three
dimensions to scale then it is two
dimensions but the idea is what a plus B
is just obtained by adding what the two
I components the two J components the
two K components and similarly for
scalar multiplication in the same way in
terms of I and J components you simply
multiplied each component by the scale
of C if C is any number and a is still
the vector a 1 I plus a 2 J plus a 3 K
the scalar multiples C times a turns out
to be C a 1 I plus C a 2 J plus C a 3 K
that you just multiply component by
component and by the way don't lose
track of this important point that the
scalar multiple CA
means the same thing in two dimensions
as it did in three because after all
when you draw that vector once that
arrow is drawn it's a one-dimensional
thing if you pick as your axis the line
of action of the particular arrow in
other words scalar multiplication means
the same thing what's happening is is
that you're looking at it in terms of
different components you're looking at
in terms of I J and K rather than just I
and J are in terms of any other
coordinate system but carrying this out
in particular notice then the connection
between the vector minus B negative B
and the vector negative 1 times B namely
the vector negative B which has the same
magnitude and direction as B but the
opposite sense is the same way of saying
what multiply B by minus 1 because that
gives you a vector which has the same
magnitude namely 1 times as much as B
the same direction and the opposite
sense in other words the vector negative
B in three-dimensional space is minus B
1 I minus B 2j minus B 3 K and therefore
since a minus B still means a plus
negative B the vector a minus B is
simply obtained how you subtract the
same way as we did in ordinary
one-dimensional analytic geometry in
terms of a number line in other words
you subtract component by component
subtracting what from the first number
minus the corresponding the first vector
minus the corresponding component of the
second vector in other words in
Cartesian coordinates the vector a minus
B once we know a 1 a 2 and a 3 as the
components of a B 1 B 2 and B 3 as the
components of B we just subtract
component by component to get this
particular result and this is I think
very important to understand by the same
token as simple as this is it's going to
cause if we're not careful
great misinterpretation namely the
vector arithmetic that we're talking
about does not depend on Cartesian
coordinates vector
arrows as we're looking at them and the
arrows exist no matter what coordinate
system we're using what is particularly
important however is that many of the
luxuries of using vector arithmetic
hinge on using Cartesian coordinates and
what do I mean by that well let me just
emphasize no the need for Cartesian
coordinates let me talk instead you see
about something called polar coordinates
now later on we're going to talk about
polar coordinates in more detail in fact
in very very much more detail but for
the time being let's view polar
coordinates simply as a radar type thing
as a range in bearing type navigation
namely in polar coordinates the way you
specify a vector in the plane say is you
specify its length which we'll call R
and the angle that it makes with the
positive x-axis that we'll call theta in
other words in polar coordinates the
vector a which I've labeled R 2 comma
theta 2 that would indicate that the
magnitude of a is R 2 and that the angle
that a makes with the positive x-axis is
Theta 2 and when I label the vector B as
R 1 comma theta 1 it's simply my way of
saying that the magnitude of the vector
B is some length which we'll call R 1
and the angle that B makes with the
positive x-axis is some angle which
we'll call theta 1 okay perfectly
well-defined system isn't it in other
words if I tell you the range in bearing
I've certainly given you as much
information as if I told you the I and J
components now here's the important
point the real kicker to this thing and
that is that the vector a minus B and a
minus B is what it's this vector here
and by the way notice how vector
everything that goes how could you tell
quickly whether this is a minus B or B
minus a we talked about this in the
previous unit and had exercises and
discussion on it but notice again the
structure of vector arithmetic if you
look at addition what is a m-- what is
this vector here this is the vector
which must be added on to be to give the
vector a and that by definition is
called what a minus B a minus B is what
vector the vector you must add onto B to
you yield a subtraction is still the
inverse of addition and hopefully by now
you should be becoming much less fearful
of this vector notation that
structurally it's the same as our first
unit of arithmetic a numerical
arithmetic okay the more regular type
ordinary type of arithmetic but here's
the important point this vector is still
a minus B but I claim that it's trivial
to see that this vector is not the
vector whose magnitude is r2 minus r1
and whose angle of bearing is data to
minus theta one now the word trivial is
a very misleading word in mathematics
one of our famous mathematical anecdotes
is the professor who said that a proof
was trivial the student says it doesn't
seem trivial to me the professor says
well it is trivial he didn't quite see
it in a hurry he says wait here he ran
down to his office came up three hours
later with a ream of papers that he had
written on bathed in perspiration and a
big smile and he said I was right it was
trivial so just because what I think is
trivial may not be what you think is
trivial let me go through this statement
in more computational detail what I'm
saying is let V denote the vector that
we called a minus B before notice that
in terms of what the vectors a and B are
this length is r1 this length is r2 and
notice that since this whole angle was
theta 2 and the angle from here to here
was theta 1 this angle in here must be
the difference between those two angles
which is Theta 2 minus theta 1
now notice that this is still a triangle
the length of this triangle is still
expressible in terms of these sides and
the included angle but you may recall
from plain trigonometry and our
refresher of that in the first part of
our course part 1 that to find the third
side of a triangle given two sides and
the included angle one must use the law
of cosines in other words the magnitude
of V has what property that it's square
is equal to the sum of the squares of
these two sides minus twice the product
of these two lengths times the cosine of
the included angle in other words this
is just
I hope this shows up all right this is
the law of cosines and if it's difficult
to read don't bother reading it it's
still the law of cosines and hopefully
you recognize it as such
in other words define the magnitude of V
it's not just R 1 or R 2 minus R 1 it's
the square root of R 1 squared plus R 2
squared minus 2 R 1 R 2 cosine theta 2
minus theta 1 can you use polar
coordinates if you want the answer is
you bet you can but when you do use it
make sure that whenever you're going to
find the magnitude that you don't just
subtract the two magnitudes you have to
use this and by the way notice I haven't
even gone into this part because it's
irrelevant from the point of view that
I'm trying to emphasize now this mess
just gives you the magnitude of the
vector it doesn't even tell you what
direction that's in I have to still do a
heck of a lot of geometry if I want to
find out what this angle here is I'm
about to work involved I can use polar
coordinates but I lose some of the
luxury of Cartesian coordinates in fact
notice that the vector R - - whose
magnitude is R 2 minus R 1 and whose
angle of bearing is Theta 2 minus theta
1 can also be computed namely how do we
find theta 2 minus theta 1 well up here
we have the angle theta 2 we have the
angle theta 1 we computed theta 2 minus
theta 1 I can now mark off that angle
here theta 2 minus theta 1 I can now
take a circle of radius R 1 or not well
Y
say a circle mock off a length r1 on to
are to assuming the r2 is the greater of
the two lengths that difference will be
r2 minus r1 in other words if I swing
and knock over here this would be r1
also this distance here would be r2
minus r1 I take that distance and Mark
it off down here and what vector is this
this is the vector which in polar
coordinates would have its magnitude
equal to r2 minus r1 and have its angle
equal to theta 2 minus theta 1 and all I
want you to see is no matter how you
slice it just from this picture alone
this vector is not the same as this
vector and by the way don't make the
mistake of saying gee the way you've
drawn them they look like they could be
the same length remember that even if by
coincidence these two vectors had the
same length
you must remember that vector equality
requires not just the same magnitude but
the same direction and even with the
same direction the same sense what
should be obvious is at least based on
this one picture that the direction of
this vector certainly is not the same as
the direction of this vector in other
words I guess I've said this many times
in part 1 and even though it comes out
like phony facetiousness I mean it quite
sincerely given two vectors and polar
coordinates one certainly has the right
to invent the vector r2 minus r1 comma
theta 2 minus comma theta 1 you
certainly have the right to do that but
you don't have the right to call that a
minus B remember I being facetious is
you have the right to call it that but
you're going to be wrong because a minus
B has already been defined and all we
have now is a choice of what the answer
looks like in a particular coordinate
system and by the way just as a quick
review assuming that you've studied
different number bases at one time in
your careers this has come up many times
in the mathematics curriculum under the
heading of number versus numeral or more
generally I call it the heading of name
versus concept
for example consider the number six six
is this many and no matter how you slice
it again this many is an even number it
breaks up into an even bundles of into
bundles of two with none left over okay
if you were to write six as a base five
numeral it's what one bundle of five
with one left over in other words notice
that the number six ends in an odd digit
in base five in other words the tests
for evenness by looking at the last
digit depends on the number base in
other words in an even base a number is
even if it's units digit is even in an
odd base a number main may or may not be
even depending on whether it's units
digit is even in other words the actual
test that you're using the actual
convenient computational property
depends on the base but the important
point is that six is always even
independently of a number base in fact
the number six as six tally marks was
invented long before place value
enumeration you see what I'm driving at
in other words the number concept stays
the same the concept stays the same what
the thing looks like in terms of a
particular set of names
that's what depends on the names that
you choose all right I think that's very
very important to see the vector
properties do not change the convenient
computational recipes do depend on what
coordinate system you're choosing and
that's one of the reasons the same is in
part one of this course why we find it
very convenient whenever possible to use
Cartesian coordinates okay and let me
just summarize this some more
structurally this is very important here
structurally arrow arithmetic is the
same for both two and three dimensions
for example without belaboring the point
whether we're dealing with
two-dimensional arrows or
three-dimensional arrows a plus b is b
plus a a plus B plus C is equal to a
plus B plus C and let me just say etc
and not belabor this particular point
that structurally we cannot tell the
difference
between two dimensional vectors and
three-dimensional vectors what we can
tell the difference between I guess is
the geometry the geometry may be more
difficult to visualize in three space
than in two space but structurally we
cannot tell the difference and I guess
this is what this thing is all about
that as you read the textbook and do
your assignment there is going to be a
tendency on your part to try to rely on
diagrams and boy you have to be an
expert in descriptive geometry to be
able to take a view of something in
three dimensions and try to get it's
true lengths as you look along various
axes and lines of sight the beauty is
going to be that as we continue on with
this course we will use geometry for
motivation but once we have motivated
things by geometry we will extract those
rules that we can use even in cases
where we can't see the picture in much
the same way going back to our first
lecture when we talked about YB to the
zero equals one we made up our rules to
make sure that they would conform with
the nice or conform to the nice
computational recipes that were
prevalent in the more simple cases and
we are going to play this thing to the
hilt we're going to really exploit this
and explore it in future lectures and in
fact throughout the rest of this course
but more about that next time and until
next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate